adrian peterson back for another season
in washington he will be 35 when the
season begins that inspired today's
draft the best old man seasons in nfl
history trivia question to chris sims
gets it right he gets the first pick as
mentioned adrian peterson will be 35
when the season begins he is the second
oldest running back to win an nfl full
season rushing title who chris sims is
the oldest running back to be the nfl
rushing champion the oldest to be the
nfl rushing champion oh man that's what
i said i know did not stutter i'm just
trying to think of somebody that i might
be missing here i just want to make sure
i'm gonna i'm gonna go with curtis
martin i don't know my god this listen
something's going on here somebody's
pressing the chris sims key and giving
you these answers you got keyshawn
johnson the other day and don't tell me
oh i was thinking of curtis martin last
night and bull crap like that some slum
dog millionaire scenario this is rigged
when are you going to believe that i am
a football historian
nfl whiz kid okay
i was the guy my family and friends
would attest to this that knew every
number and player in the nfl at like the
age of five and i'm not embellishing
that like i really was that psycho guy
so deal with it damn i'm good whoa i am
good you all right okay
okay
i'm gonna go with john elway all right
that's gonna be my first pick i mean
john elway
you know at the age of 38 years old
goes to the super bowl has an
unbelievable year with the denver
broncos where they're the number one
seed in the afc and then goes out in his
last game ever to win a super bowl and a
super bowl mvp where he threw bombs and
ran for a touchdown and did a number of
great things in that game down in miami
against the atlanta falcons so to me
that is an ultimate old man season he
was deciding on whether to come back or
not he decides to come back of course
they play great he gets hurt during the
year and has to deal with some injuries
and all that
but still
shows john elway magic down the stretch
and i mean come on it just doesn't get
much better than
walking off the field for your whole
career as a super bowl champ and a super
bowl mvp so i'm going to give him the
best old guy season in nfl history
yeah you know that's not a bad pick
you're right to be the mvp of the super
bowl to walk off into the sunset 38
although 38 seems a little spring
chicken-ish i know by today's fair right
we're only gonna you can't do that
because they're like i know it's it's
not fair but 38 that's right we got to
make sure we explain this to people 38
at that time period was like really old
that was like the 42 of tom brady right
now i mean really right am i
embellishing that no no no no it wasn't
that long ago when matt hasselbeck
decided to play one more year and he was
gonna turn 40. i went and looked to see
which quarterbacks managed to make it to
40 and how they played at 40 or older
and there was a small list right it just
doesn't happen but it is happening now
with two guys we are in the golden age
of quarterbacks great young quarterbacks
great old quarterbacks and this may be
the last year that we have both tom
brady and drew brees and speaking of tom
brady he wasn't the super bowl mvp that
year he would have been if the
patriots had simply played malcolm
butler against an eagles offense that
the new england defense couldn't stop
tom brady was the regular season mvp in
2017 at the age of 40. and look i know
38 was 42 in 1998 but 40 is still 40 and
it had been a long time if not ever that
a 40 year old quarterback had had that
kind of season but to be the nfl mvp at
the age of 40 is incredible yeah there's
no other mvp of the nfl that was 40 and
there may never be another one no it is
incredible there's no i mean brady has
rewritten the the record books with how
to take care of yourself your body you
know stay
physically tip-top that way and then of
course you know we've talked about it i
mean he's just his arm hasn't lost many
mile per hour so he could still make
every throw in the book and you're right
i mean hey then why then why are you
doubting the concept of teams like the
titans wanting him or the cowboys
wanting him why are you putting him in
the middle of the pack the guy was the
mvp of the freaking nfl at at age 40.
right that was three yeah he could do it
43 years ago and it declines in a hurry
at this age as you've seen i mean it
does so that's why i mean that i i
understand that was an amazing year and
it was an amazing super bowl you and i
were both there in minnesota for that
and for in a losing effort is about as
good as i've ever seen a quarterback
play because he really didn't make any
mistakes the whole freaking game he was
amazing all right i'm gonna go to
another 40 year old quarterback i mean
he didn't win the mvp
but damn it was an mvp worthy type of
season and that's brett favre in 2009
with your minnesota vikings yeah you
were gonna pick that weren't you yes i
was yeah but that was an amazing season
i mean first off he came off the year
where he was with the jets and it got
off to that hard that hot start and it
kind of fell off and he went oh i don't
know you know is it how much does brett
favre have left but then he goes to
minnesota they go 12-4 he throws 33
touchdown passes and seven interceptions
and 4 200 yards i mean very easily could
have won the mvp right was that the year
that adrian peterson rushed for 2000 and
peyton manning had a big year and they
stopped the mvp no who won the mvp in 09
i didn't look up but those are mvp type
numbers regarding manning no no no no
yeah it was peyton manning
yeah so but that was a remarkable year
and yeah football historian football
historian didn't know the 2009 mvp well
i said peyton manning i just thought it
was the year he split it with adventure
peter said you threw out seven names i
did throughout seven i said was that the
year that adrian peterson and peyton
manning i knew peyton manning had won it
that year i just wasn't sure if that was
a year or not shut up you jerk you're
just mad because i took your vikings
pick and that vikings pick that should
have been in the super bowl what they
lost in the nfc championship game was
just another big blow to your fandom
because old man brett favre decides to
throw the ball across his body and field
goal range causing paul allen our good
friend to ultimately crank himself up
into a frenzy with his famous this is
not detroit man it's the super bowl line
uh and then the saints were going to win
that game in overtime and then they
would go on to beat mvp peyton manning
in super bowl 44 next one for me and
this is going to make stats happy he was
pushing this one earlier
in 2002 at the age of 40 yeah jerry rice
in his second season with the raiders
1211 receiving yards with 92 catches
at the age of 40. amazing accomplishment
for the greatest receiver of all time
and really the guy who was regarded as
the consensus greatest player of all
time at any position until tom brady
made that a more interesting discussion
yeah but uh there was no one like jerry
rice and uh he played until he was 42
although in his 42 year old
uh it uh it
didn't go well 429 receiving yards but
uh tom brady going one year beyond jerry
rice we'll see how brady does this year
but rice tapped out at 42 but still at
40 he was still great proving your point
that uh from 40 to 43 a lot can happen a
lot can happen you know it is and it's
still amazing and that was that would
have probably been my next pick if you
didn't go there because that was an
amazing year i mean jerry rice at the
receiver position to be doing that at
that point and still being like a number
one target and what's even crazier is
they had a guy tim brown who was you
know almost just as old over there doing
great things too on that team it was
just uh that was that was an amazing
that was a fun team to watch that that
rich gannon oakland raiders football
team
all right so i'm i'm you know i almost
want to pick my dad my dad had a great
my dad was the oldest quarterback ever
to start a playoff game you know when he
retired he was 38 and they they beat
your vikings again uh to win that one
but i'm not gonna go with that screw you
phil sims okay we're gonna come up with
something better i'm gonna go with
peyton manning all right in 2013 at the
age of 37 right that that to me
to
the year where yeah the physical skills
were on decline you could see it at that
point already but he still had good
enough skills and then his brain
and ability to check and do things at
the line of scrimmage was just on
another level i mean that's why peyton
manning is one of the five greatest
quarterbacks of all time not only was he
talented but he was like you know having
an offensive coordinator on the field
playing quarterback too and that year
and i just want to make sure i get this
right i mean
5400 passing yards all-time record 55
touchdown passes
10 interceptions you know ended up in
the super bowl loss but i don't care
what anybody says that was a special
special year at 37 years old and his
first year on a new team
where on the very first snap of the game
it went over his
head out of the end zone two nothing
seattle and it went downhill from there
all right i like it i like it i i'm
gonna finish though where we started we
started with a washington running back
who is going to be 35 years old this
season so we should end with a
washington running back you're going
regular 35 years old i'm going regular
1239 rushing yards and 14 touchdowns at
the age of 35. it's amazing look if if
adrian peterson does that we'll say oh
my god this is unprecedented no it's not
john riggins did it at age 35 for the
same team that's why i think it's
beautiful that washington picked up the
option same team same age
and uh adrian peterson slightly higher
on the all-time rushing uh list but uh
you know john riggins uh hey
he's a guy who gets overlooked there's
nothing like that fourth and short run
against the dolphins and super bowl 17
where you know the game's in the balance
it's a close exciting super bowl we
haven't seen many of those and he just
busts through and he's gone yeah i mean
he was an iconic player during his era
and 1239 rushing yards at the age of 30.
yeah extremely talented you're right way
more talented than i think that people
give them credit for
workhorse physical freak i mean again
mike you know me with ass and legs you
want to talk about a special pair right
there look at that i mean it is special
and it's amazing he did that at that age
that really is and am i right didn't he
take a year off from football the year
before right am i not am i right about
that i thought he took the year off
before he had that year you're saying at
35 years old i could be wrong okay no i
think at some point in the 70s he he uh
uh 19 19
yeah and here's here's my here let me
tell you this and we gotta oh we got a
little time
my first awareness of john riggins came
in the mid 70s when i discovered the
tops football cards
and i have this john reagan's card and
i'm sure it's here in the archives it's
up here somewhere in the attic above my
garage
and he's got this giant
bush of hair he's got an outfit he's
like right it's gigantic how do you get
a helmet over it yeah it's like out
there here so that was my first who's
this john riggins guy so uh yeah he
ended up being pretty good players with
the jets before he was with washington
crank up that deal
all right uh let's recap real quick no i
don't let's recap real quick and head to
break your picks best old man seasons
john elway in 98 brett favre 2009 peyton
manning two thousand women
screw you phil sims uttered along the
way by chris who didn't pick his own dad
for a change i got brady in 2017 jerry
rice in 2002 john riggins
1984. hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports